where would Jake Gyllenhaal Tom Holland
and zendaya as they shut down Hollywood
Boulevard thank you so much for coming
guys thank you this is intense where
does this go after go to Hollywood and
this kind of stuff happens
[Music]
our Spidey fashion senses were tingling
last night at the spider-man far from
home premiere tell me about the look
because this is very Spider Man it this
was our our um our homage to the far
from home suit that he wears so this is
my own version meanwhile the men were
having their own fashion moment and we
couldn't help but notice Jake and Tom
had a little night at the Roxbury thing
happening
[Music]
you know Jake and I wearing the same
shoes tonight and I'm wearing them way
better than him if you had to pick a
favorite Avengers bromance for yourself
Tom
well me and Downey isn't really a
bromance it's like a father-son mance
which is a little creepy but wet snow
creepy we're just yeah I do have to be
Jake you and Tom spent time at a
Children's Hospital in costume it was
just a wonderful afternoon and it's
lovely to see the smiles on their faces
it's a surprise Tom never landed himself
in the hospital considering he did most
of his own stunts honestly like we were
so used to him doing it know that it's
kind of like just part of it
[Music]
for me when it comes to doing the stunts
I've always been quite an athletic
person and I've always loved gymnastics
so I'm a specimen anyway so it's just a
word for me it's been really fun to be
able to like push myself to kind of a
new level with the stunts and stuff you
don't want any part of this I'm laying
on the ground the end of this battle and
he he's supposed to enter that's what
was written but instead when I got to
set there's a trampoline on set and the
dude jumps on the trampoline does two
backflips and lands on eight like
spider-man and then starts the scene and
I was like what's going on as long as
you can do it it's fun I got this really
dope stunt man that everyone believes is
me and I watch the movie Oh me me me me
County me me me me me can't no I
couldn't do that when I was today
yeah there's the most amazing footage of
you and it's spider-man taking a drink
on set yeah it's an interesting
contraption to say the least what I can
do is I can take my left eye out and
there's a little like thing I pull out
and then I put a squeezy tube down into
my mouth and then I can drink from a
bottle what I found out is if I push the
mask forward I can now squeeze like dum
and stuff Oh down the eyehole
[Music]